[Captions by Mary V. at Y Translator]
In our last video,
we showed you how to assemble
some of the electronics
inside our flame thrower arm,
and in today's video, we'll be finishing
those up and testing it out on my arm.
[Music]
One propane canister
runs out fairly quickly.
So I decided I wanted
to add a second one.
I wanted to build something
that would let me use
two propane canisters at the same time
for double the fuel capacity.
For that, we turned back to our
small little brass pipe fitting pieces.
This is what I came up with.
We've got our valve.
In fact we've got two of them.
This is what we built
earlier by soldering on pieces.
You can see the copper,
little pieces soldered onto both.
We can see the knobs faces soldered closed,
so there's no leakage there.
On one side, it's pretty direct.
The valve goes through
an elbow into the T
which threads down into our barb.
What we can do is we start
with this side, with it closed,
thread our tank onto here,
thread our other tank
on to the other side,
then we can open and
we have both tanks at once
feeding down into the barb.
And then I've got this.
This is just a block of wood.
I cut out of a plywood.
It's sort of T-shaped that lets
the hose clamps grip on
and hold it firmly in place.
And I've added a little elbow
bracket onto the top of that,
which is what I can use to
attach this whole weird assembly
onto the skeleton arm frame.
And now I can bolt that on right there.
I've drilled two holes into the frame.
That goes right there.
Now, if I just had this
mounted onto the arm,
and two full propane tanks above it,
that would be a lot of stress
on this one little piece right here.
So we wanted to build a support
that could hold everything in place
a little bit higher up on the bottles.
We're just gonna cut
that out of a piece of wood.
[Music]
Looks like about 2 and 13/16
inches is the diameter of our bottles.
Take a compass, measure out
a circle just the right size.
But just the right size mean just a hint
bigger so it's not gonna scrape and rub.
We're gonna go for some open circles.
They won't be entirely
enclosed by the board.
Have it be open on one
end just a little bit.
Let's see. I'd say we've also got
some extra board back here.
So we'll trim that down a bit too.
[Music]
Our piece of wood is cut out,
and if we measured it correctly,
the bottles can fit through this,
and then directly into their valves.
So I've got two propane cans
that are completely empty.
There's nothing left in these.
They don't hiss when
you push down the pins.
Nothing remnant so I'm not gonna
be risking filling the air
with propane as I do this.
There we have it.
Two propane cans,
and as I just said these
are both completely empty
that's why nothing is venting out here.
These are just drained.
So now I can mount
this onto the arm skeleton,
and it should hold those pretty nicely.
I've got one elbow bracket right here.
Let's throw a second elbow
bracket onto this piece,
and that'll let us attach both of them.
[Music]
Lovely lovely lovely.
This brace is working well.
It's holding our canisters
right where we want them.
All right next up.
We're going to want
to attach the solenoid,
and then run the hose from
this barb into the solenoid.
Where did I put the solenoid?
The solenoid conveniently
for mounting has a couple of spots
on the bottom with threads in it.
So, we can use a couple of machine
threaded screws to attach that.
And to attach it to the arm,
we've got a couple of
holes drilled into the metal.
Our hose reaches to the solenoid,
and in fact, we've got
quite a bit of extra hose.
So, what we want to
do is cut it to a length
so that it easily reaches when
my arm is bent or straightened out.
All right.
Straight, bent, both ways.
That hose reaches just fine.
In order to dump the propane out,
we need to be able
to activate the solenoid.
And to do that, we have
our battery pack of course.
So we need somewhere
to put the battery pack.
I've got some space up here
in between the propane tanks,
and it seems like it would
be a shame to waste that.
So I'm gonna see if I can't
attach our battery pack up here.
[Music]
There we go.
That's held nicely in place.
We're gonna take apart this umbrella
and use the spring-loaded metal bars
as a sort of extending arm
and try and make our prongs
reach out onto the front of that
so all of the electricity is just
a good distance in front of our arm.
That way there shouldn't
be any fire on our hand,
there shouldn't be any
taser leads on our hands.
It should just be safer all around.
[whistling]
Okay, I think I need to
completely destroy this umbrella.
The umbrella mechanism
is pretty simple here.
We've got one metal rod that
fits closely inside of another one.
There's a lock that doesn't
move until you press down on that.
Collapses down.
Normally what holds it in the down
position to some other hardware
that I've already stripped off.
We do have these little barbs down here.
But they don't latch on
to anything at the moment.
So what I need to do is cut
a hole in the metal right here
so that it'll little hook on to those.
That way when I push
this button, it should spring out.
[Music]
We've got the hole cut well filed in.
So now we can bring this back,
and it latches into place.
And when we push this button down,
it shoots forward.
As you saw, it's quite difficult
to push that button down.
This spike is a little more
intense than we need it to be.
So once again we'll gonna the file,
we're gonna keep the spike there.
We're gonna shorten it,
so we don't have to push
quite so hard on this button.
[Music]
Here is what we're going to use
to extend those taser diodes.
I have these two leads that have
sort of a ceramic non-conductive back,
and of course the metal up front.
At the back of these leads,
I have soldered on these two wires,
and covered the backs
in some liquid electrical tape.
And I'm now actually going to put
several more layers of stuff over that
to make absolutely sure
that the electricity isn't going
to try and arc between
the wires back here,
and that it really sticks
to the leads where I want it.
We're also going to attach these
onto the front of this telescoping rod,
And now need to drill a hole big
enough for the screw to fit in,
and I'm then going to
add some proto putty.
Just some silicone
mixed up with some water,
and maybe a little bit of cornstarch
to just build up around here.
Now, if we attach this
umbrella bar right about here,
we should be able to press this button,
and it will extend automatically.
So we need to attach
the umbrella bar onto the frame.
To do that, we've got
a hole drilled right here.
We'll drill a hole into this,
and use a bolt to hold that in place.
[Music]
All right, this arm is
attached on one side,
but doesn't have much
support on the other.
So what I think we're
gonna do is take this eyebolt.
We will attach that onto the front
of the frame right about here,
and that will just sort of
be a spot where this can rest.
And we'll then tighten this bolt down
once we have an angle we want.
And the advantage of the eyebolt
is that it should hold it in place,
and as it extends outward,
it should be able to slide along that.
Still giving a little bit of support,
but without gripping it
so it doesn't slide easily.
[Music]
That's what we're looking for.
I needed a handle to be able to control
both the gas and electricity at once.
This was originally part
of a wrist rocket,
and I thought I could repurpose it
to be my little double trigger handle.
So what I've done is
cut three holes into it.
I've got a rectangle hole
that I cut in right here,
and then I've got two more holes
that I drilled down in the bottom.
And then it already had
one hole in the top
that happened to be just the right size.
So what we've got is a couple
of different kinds of switches.
So this switch is designed to
do something rather particular.
You can have electricity going into it,
and you can have something
that is activated by the switch,
and then something that is always on.
The second wire is the one
you want to be conditional.
We are actually not going
to be using this wire,
the one that is always on.
So we're just going to cut that off.
Now this switch can mount inside
the rectangle hole that I cut out.
And if I leave enough space,
I can still click it.
We've also got this little
push button switch.
Both switches only allow electricity to
flow through as the button is held down.
This one I'm gonna put on top and
it's gonna be the activation for the taser,
and then pulling
the trigger will drop the fuel.
Beautiful.
We now have two separate
switches we can activate.
Click click click click.
Let's use a couple more zip ties
to attach our switches
to this other piece of aluminum.
[Music]
From a functional standpoint,
this flame thrower arm
should be ready to go.
I think we need to give it a test.
[Music]
Let's try this sucker out.
[laughing]
Yes!
We're not using it a whole lot right now.
Basically, we're just showing
you that it is functional,
and I'm pretty happy with
where we've gotten this to.
It does work.
It shoots fire.
It's not mounted to a chair anymore.
I can carry it around.
It's got some heft to it.
It's not exactly a super comfortable
flame thrower arm but it does work.
All of it is mounted just
on one arm right there.
This thing is pretty sweet.
Stay tuned for part three where
we decorate this whole thing,
in some cool cosplay style armor
and make it look like a giant robotic arm.
Guys as always, we've got
more for you to see,
so you don't miss out on the fun.
This box up at the top will
take you to our last video.
That's a good one.
You should go check that out.
The box down at the bottom is
gonna show you what YouTube
thinks you need to be watching,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe you in the channel.
This is how you make sure you don't miss
out on anything cool we do in the future.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.